with the makeup artists and hairstylists
involved in the iron lady are listed in
your program
needless to say this is not the first
film for any of these nominees and
you'll find their film credits bios and
awards in your
program please welcome
all of our
nominees back onto the stage
before we start our question and answer
portion i'd like to read remarks made
this year by steven spielberg
at the producers guild awards when he
received the david o'sul david al
selznick award
he said no one can sink no one can
succeed alone
an evening like this reminds me that for
every film and tv show nominated tonight
someone reached out to give you their
hand
whether all of us are working together
or competing
inside this very small creative
community we're always holding
somebody's hand and i'm grateful to feel
all of yours holding mine right now
i think that's so perfect
for
academy awards for every film that is
done
as we start the question answer period
there are going to be uh ushers in the
uh
in the aisles they'll have microphones
so if you have a question just raise
your hand uh and we'll try to get to
your questions that way everybody can
hear the question
i have just a couple of questions
just real quick
um
roy would you tell a story i think we
can tell that story
um you said that when merrill
when they were doing the casting and
they did the casting of the young
margaret
thatcher well yes when
when this movie was put together
they all thought this is really great
and they'll
do a little something to merrill and
we'll go ahead
which is why
when we were lucky enough to find mark
and
they didn't really have in the budget
that we were going to do any screen
tests of any kind
but that expanded and then oh well yes i
guess we'll have to do a little bit of
something with um
with jim broadband uh so what that added
and then alexandra was cast and she was
brought in and she's lovely and meryl
turned and she said she's lovely and she
turned to mark and she said
you'll have to make her a nose
because
alexander has a little beautiful nose
and she said
that nose won't grow into mine in 20
years
so that added
a little more and then
it just grew so it ended up that there
was a lot a lot of prosthetics in the
movie and
every principal had teeth
didn't they at one time say oh no no we
don't have that in the budget we won't
be able to do that every day every day
every day
but if i'm right merrill looked at him
and said
there's either there's a nose or or i go
at all
it has to be if you can do it it has to
be done right
yeah and i think it's a great stand when
uh you know actors or actresses uh make
sure that that happens
a lot of times we see it not happen
um
okay let's let's start with some
questions from the audience
this is for the harry potter crew
especially dick and amanda when you
design initially characters for the
early films or characters that are in
four five six films once you do the
design for the initial film is that
pretty much it or does it evolve with
subsequent films
do you want me to start oh you do want
me to start right okay
um
i think we just improv tried to improve
everything all the time i mean obviously
you can't dramatically change a
character because in a series because
you'll wreck the continuity but we would
review on any movie whether something in
the last thing could be improved upon
sometimes we did change things professor
flitwick warwick davis was a sort of
white puff ball-haired little character
in the first two movies and then he
turned into a sort of dark-haired guy
with a heinrich himmler haircut um
because alfonso the director of the
third one just wanted him to be like
that
we all said well we can't call him
flipwick and
but after a few movies you just called
him flitwick and there is no continuity
and we don't care
but you would review if something could
be improved you know if you were doing a
particular job you would look at the
molds again you would look at you know
beards or things again if something
could be improved upon we were on a
series where you could do that
hairstylist friend of mine a number of
years ago said
don't match if you can make it better
another question
this is for the two makeup artists from
europe do you see anything
in general any differences between
makeup artistry training or working in
europe as compared to the united states
i think
there's so much uh
mix between europe and the states that
all the skills
intermingle and everybody learns from
everybody else so not really you don't
see too much for difference
i could say that um in england
there isn't a structured teaching scheme
um there's lots of colleges and lots of
private schools you can go to and part
with a lot of money some of them are
very good some aren't um
i don't know because i've never worked
over here
on a major movie i don't know how it's
structured here but it does seem to me
that to work on movies over here it is
tougher
um
at home
if i want to hire somebody
they can come and see me show me their
portfolio and their last job could have
been
you know in a supermarket and we can
hire them
we have there we have a union
i what's it called
exactly um
they used to have tests and all of that
kind of thing um but
it just frittered away
which does mean in europe there are lots
of people who say they're makeup artists
or hairdressers and there's lots of very
good ones there's also a lot of people
who have no right to the name whatsoever
and there is no policing of it
it's a little bit different in ireland
you either are a hair person or a makeup
person and it's quite rigid people stick
to that i think
our union's a little bit stronger but
we don't have um exams it's all based on
the level of experience you acquire as
time goes on whether you upgrade to the
next level or not
but they have you have apprentice
programs
which we don't have here you have lots
and lots of apprentices on films
and they're
um yes we do great help and it's a
fabulous training for them well we did
decide i mean i've always taken a
trainee or two where i can um
productions love it because it's cheap
labor but
i like it because you get a very
enthusiastic young crew on potter we
actually had a kind of program
of bringing in six or eight people on
every movie and moving them through the
department so there were people on the
latter potters who've never worked on
anything else come in as a trainee made
tea swept the floor been insulted or
caught out by mark coulier who does
dreadful things to trainees
and they ended up running it you know
they end up running departments um
and
they've got to learn it
i didn't say it was a bad thing
i'd just like to say that that nick nick
is very generous
taking people on and giving them the
opportunity so he actually acts as um a
a a trainer um and a lot of people i've
been on the harry potter films for
10 years and there's a lot of very
talented people come through nick's
department and amanda and lisa's
department too and uh they always say
that they learn more in a week of
working in a in a workshop than they do
after partying with thousands of pounds
on a on a training course for six six
months another question
my question is for the potter cast mark
coulier included
in
10 years of working with potter which
was your favorite movie to work on
should we start at this end amanda
um mine was azkaban um
it was just it was
one of the best we were given so much it
was the serious black uh character came
from that and um alfonso who directed
that was just so creative he had such
strong ideas and um
it fed through he let's try all sorts of
different things
um i'd have to say two i would say the
last movie because we had the most
prosthetic makeup we'd ever done in it
and i think it was the best prosthetic
makeup that any of us had ever produced
um just through learning and going over
it but i also have to say number four
because we did build a fire breathing
dragon
and i promise you there is no fun like
having a real fire breathing dragon
to play
with and mine was the half blood prince
because that was the first one i
designed
and
it was great to take over some of the
characters that had already been in the
films before and sort of put my mark on
them so i really like that one the best
i think
and uh for me it was the the last two
just because um after
getting voldemort and introducing him
it was great to actually have him on
screen a bit more in the last one so
that one for me another question
i got a question for
the european
artist for harry potter and
albert knobs i i live part of the year
in argentina and my friend's there i'm a
singer-songwriter and social activist
just curious
in argentina
margaret thatcher's is not at all
popular northern chile so my filmmaker
friends said they would never ever work
on a film
in regards to martha thatcher so i'm
just kind of curious
would you ever object as an artist to
work on a film thank you
would you ever object as a as an artist
to work on a film whose person's
politics you disagree with
can i go first i hated margaret thatcher
i did everything that she did we had so
many unemployed at the time but
it was the you know we're more
interested in in creating a character
really and the chance to work with uh a
fantastic actress like meryl streep it's
you know i put the my thoughts about
margaret thatcher aside and for the the
benefits far outweighed the the
you know my political ideals
another question one over here
uh this is about the iron lady i'm a
hair stylist for 45 years and
excited and proud to have this
occupation i noticed on the wigs there
was always a little white
root like the regrowth and i thought it
made it seem very very natural instead
of having it so dark at the scalp and
also roy if you would tell them you
mentioned downstairs about the earrings
when they were filming
the earrings that you would put on so
meryl would remember to put them on
that was a different film
earrings were a different film um
uh yes it was
the decision
like i said
i had to level out all the colors
because they were
quite different
and
when we built the
old age hair
it had to be we
knew it had to
look
thinner
more frail
more permed
and so um
peter owen
built me this fabulous wig that was
quite thin
um
and
many fabulous colors of gray and then i
dyed it down to i told them i was doing
a quarter inch but of course it's
closer to 5 8 because i knew i needed
that
um
just dyed it down to that so that it we
knew it was an old woman with dyed hair
because
otherwise it would have just been
the same as any of the other wigs
another question
here
more difficult to
design the makeup and the hair
now that the cameras are so advanced
as far as seeing so much more than let's
say 10 or 20 years ago is that a
challenge that you have on most of the
films
and also the lighting
that it has improved so far technically
well i think the wig laces have changed
a lot over the years so we're actually
quite lucky because the
wig lace that i use is extremely fine
but otherwise it would be very difficult
especially with hd in 3d now
definitely
okay we have time for one more question
a question from mark you had the
opportunity to work on two
uh films that seemed to have distinct
challenges
one was to recreate a recent historical
figure and the other was to create
imaginary characters
did you find do you prefer one or the
other did you find what are the
challenges or what are the differences
in those two uh different challenges um
i i like um a variety i was talking to
somebody a few days ago about it um
we've just done a movie um with
creating hundreds of zombies and
you know we go from potter where we're
creating iconic villains or inflating
fat ladies or goblins in the bank
they all bring their
challenges um
and then creating a real
political figure and
uh
and then aging doing an aging makeup as
well they all bring their challenge to
the
variety is the best thing you know
doing the same thing time and again is
is is not fun
uh but even on the potter films we've
done 10 10 films but each film had
totally different things in it you know
i know voldemort reappears but each time
you do the voldemort character but
there's other things to do as well and
when we do the goblins we're trying to
reinvent everything and make them look
look more real and nicer so
the
there's always uh it's the variety
really keeps us interested
also i should say that in in mark's
spare time
between
the iron lady and
harry potter he also made the uh
headpiece for leonardo dicaprio
for jay edgar so the piece that went up
through here with the punched hair was
something that mark did
sort of you know in his spare time
yeah we've done one for um
we've done one for kevin bacon uh for
the beginning of x-men first class
because he didn't want to cut his hair
for so in the opening of x-men in the
opening sequence kevin bacon's got a
full
ball cap on with hair punched and it
worked really well and they'd seen it
sean grigg and duncan german who
designed the leonardo dicaprio maker had
seen it and they didn't have time to do
it and we we'd done the process once so
that we were able to replicate the
process and do it pretty pretty quickly
yeah we fit that in somehow i don't know
how
okay be sure uh tomorrow night watch the
academy awards on abc
um
we're going to go downstairs for a
wonderful reception you'll be able to
see
our nominees down there and one more big
round of applause for all of these
people
you